E aí
Olá eu sou a Patrícia mãe da Nike e da
Ivi Filha da maria do Arthur neta da
amélia da Iolanda do Dorival do Guinho
da esperança e do José irmã da Adriana e
da Camila irmã da Rose e amiga de um
punhado de gente boa e desde criança
sempre foi assim Eu sempre andei de
bando eu sempre entende a força que tem
no coletivo sempre tive coragem de andar
com muita gente e fazer disso a minha
grande força desde criança Eu sempre
andei de bando e mesmo sem entender o
conceito de Ubuntu ele sempre esteve ali
presente a força do nós a força do
coletivo alguns anos atrás eu me vires
Encantada profissionalmente e me vesti
de um provérbio que eu tinha conhecido
na época que dizia e que recomendava
fortemente que quando a gente não sabe
para onde ir a gente tem que olhar para
trás e
a gente veio e nesse mergulho lá para o
meu passado eu me vi num lugar que eu
passei longos anos da minha vida longos
e deliciosos anos a casa da minha avó e
mais precisamente na cozinha dela aquele
espaço pequeno e grandioso ao mesmo
tempo e muito mágico que tinha tudo que
importava para mim a família ali a gente
tinha a televisão a máquina de costura a
máquina de lavar roupa o rádio além das
panelas e dos temperos da minha avó a
minha avó é uma mulher que dizia que eu
tinha que ir na feira logo cedo porque
depois das 10 horas da manhã não tinha
nada que prestava e hoje eu sou uma
mulher que entende o que depois das 10 e
lá para o fim da feira é que tá a nossa
grande oportunidade de Honrar o alimento
horário da Xepa eu sempre foi motivo de
riso entre as minhas amigas porque elas
iam para a feira com uma lista muito
simples era alface tomate
e já eu ia com a lista da minha avó que
tinha além do alface do tomate e da
Batata a chicória escarola catalonia o
almeirão comida para minha família
sempre foi motivo de festa não
cozinhávamos por que haveria uma festa
haveria uma festa porque seriam cozidos
feijões feijoadas macarronadas saladas
de batata e toda a riqueza que tinha na
comida da minha avó já adulta eu quis
pegar todas essas referências da minha
família e colocar num grande caldeirão
que ia cozinhar a minha nova trajetória
profissional e nessa trajetória eu
passei por restaurantes acompanhei
grande chefes tive a sorte de participar
de grandes projetos conhecer fazendas
conversar com Agricultores
a entender cada vez mais a força que tem
na agroecologia e quando eu entendi isso
eu vi que aquela comida que sempre foi
motivo de festa hoje é um ato político a
minha sacola de compras ela reflete seja
no mercado seja na feira as minhas
atitudes e o meu posicionamento a minha
sacola ela tenta não ser de plástico
porque eu não sei de onde veio aquele
material e eu não faço a menor ideia de
todo o caminho que o plástico vai fazer
para ir embora quando eu decidi que ele
não vale mais para minha casa a Paty é
só jogar fora mas jogar fora onde onde é
esse lugar que a gente joga fora esse
lugar Generoso que acolhe não só o
plástico o papel e o alumínio mas tudo
aquilo que a gente não sabe ou não quer
reaproveitar os talos das verduras as
raízes das Ervas aquelas frutas mais
amassado
e aquelas folhas não estão verdinhos dos
legumes que lugar é esse e assim como a
minha sacola o meu prato ele também fala
comigo tempo todo e ele me faz perguntas
Ele quer saber de onde veio aquele arroz
Quem produziu aquele feijão Qual foi o
tempo que a cenoura levou do campo até a
minha mesa Será que tem veneno nesse
tomate Será que o produtor desse vegetal
receber um preço justo pela produção
desse alimento e esse meu prato com
todos esses questionamentos ele tem a
força de honrar os meus antepassados e
os meus ancestrais ele cuida muito bem
do meu presente e ele tem muita
esperança no futuro aquele futuro não
tão distante que na verdade é agora e
que nos convoca a desperdiçar cada vez
menos a reaproveitar tudo o que for
possível a não ficar
e conformados com o fato de que tem
comida no nosso prato sendo que lá fora
muita gente tá passando fome esse prato
questionador que cada vez que ele me faz
uma pergunta ele me enche de coragem de
pedir para que todos nós juntos
consigamos construir esse mundo onde
cada vez menos a gente disemba lá e cada
vez mais a gente descasca muito obrigada
[Aplausos]
E aí